[Música]
el delantero francés del real madrid
karim benzema fue condenado un año de
cárcel exento de cumplimiento y una
multa de 75 mil euros por complicidad en
el intento de chantaje con un vídeo
sexual a su ex compañero en la selección
mathieu valbuena benzema apelar a la
decisión
colombia celebra los 5 años de la firma
del acuerdo final de paz entre el
gobierno y la antigua guerrilla de las
farc con diversos actos a los que
asistirá el secretario general de la onu
antonio guterres es de visita en el país
a propósito de la fecha de eeuu informó
que planea retirar a las farc de su
lista de grupos terroristas
hoy hace 30 años la leyenda del rock
freddie mercury murió en su casa en
kensington reino unido después de
anunciar que era vih positivo o el fin
de una era en la que faraón compulsará
se propuso conquistar al mundo y lo hizo
muy buen día gracias por continuar con
nosotros en france 24 sirve a blanco
como siempre un gusto acompañarlos y
comenzamos en francia donde el delantero
del real madrid karim benzema fue
condenado este miércoles a un año de
cárcel exento de cumplimiento y una
multa de 75 mil euros por complicidad en
el intento de chantaje con un vídeo
sexual de su ex compañero en la
selección francesa mathieu valbuena el
veredicto del tribunal de versalles es
más duro que la petición de la fiscalía
que había solicitado una pena de 10
meses de prisión exentos de cumplimiento
contra el jugador que no se presentó a
la lectura de su sentencia y tampoco lo
hizo durante los tres días del proceso
hace un mes benzema acudirá al juicio en
apelación del caso valbuena el abogado
se refirió a la sentencia y reiteró la
apelación
las reacciones de enfado por esta
sentencia que es perfectamente
contradictoria de hecho el propio
tribunal declaró claramente que karim
benzema no estaba al tanto de las
maniobras previas y luego al final se
nos dice que no lo pudo haber sabido sin
pruebas y esto lo que condenamos
condenamos esta sentencia muy severa que
es injusta sin pruebas realmente estamos
bastante pasmados por este juicio así se
dijo asimismo la peli de nuevos son
obviamente es necesario una apelación y
debemos apelar porque karim benzema no
tiene nada de culpa en este caso y será
absuelto en el tribunal de apelación
show de la cruda pero el presidente
francés emmanuel lemma cron se reúne
este miércoles con el consejo de defensa
para definir las medidas a tomar para
contrarrestar el nuevo brote de kobe 19
en el país expertos recomendaron la
dosis de refuerzo y uso de mascarilla el
ejecutivo busca un fortalecimiento de la
respuesta sanitaria el brote francia
registró más de 30.000 nuevas
infecciones porque 19 en las últimas 24
horas por primera vez desde el mes de
agosto
y en las islas de ultramar francesas las
nuevas medidas impuestas para
contrarrestar el kobe 19 desataron
protestas en guadalupe y martinica que
han terminado en enfrentamientos con las
autoridades pero el rechazo a las
medidas es sólo la punta del iceberg del
problema social que lleva años y que
francia aún no ha solucionado veamos el
informe que ha preparado andrés
granadillo
la crisis en las islas francesas de
ultramar se agudiza la ira por las
medidas impuestas para controlar el cob
y 19 por las que ahora es obligatoria la
vacunación para los trabajadores de la
salud avivaron un problema social
latente las tasas de vacunación en los
territorios son inferiores a las del
continente los habitantes de las islas
de guadalupe y martinica se han sentido
marginados durante mucho tiempo por el
gobierno central en este evento la la
ayuda desconfianza fuerte pero que no es
nueva vimos muchas manifestación muchas
huelgas esos últimos años entonces esto
está enmarcado justamente en un fenómeno
que se está ya llevando desde hace años
la desconfianza de las élites francesas
del poder central jacoby mismo además
bien en una realidad económica muy
diferente en la que se vive en francia
continental es un problema de desempleo
un problema de costo de vida que es más
o menos 12% más caro que en francia el
nivel de pobreza es dos veces superior
es decir que hay una desigualdad total
que se puede justamente sentir y no hay
lucha real el tema de conocer la
aplicabilidad que conocer justamente las
protestas marcan una prueba para el
gobierno del presidente manuel macro no
hay olvidar que esta isla ha votado por
mayoría por macro dónde en la la las
anteriores elecciones entonces se
pensaban justamente tener más apoyo del
gobierno central y en este momento no le
están teniendo los disturbios se
producen en un momento difícil para
francia a menos de cinco meses de las
elecciones presidenciales y las
autoridades de nueva zelanda anunciaron
que no abrirán sus fronteras a viajeros
extranjeros hasta abril de 2022 lo que
si podrán entrar antes son los
nacionales y residentes vacunados el
gobierno indicó que el 16 de enero
levantarán las restricciones a los niños
el andés es y aquellos con permiso de
residencia que vuelvan desde australia y
a partir del 13 de febrero desde todo el
resto del mundo
hoy se cumplen cinco años de la firma de
los acuerdos de paz en colombia' entre
el gobierno y la desaparecida guerrilla
de las farc que puso fin a 50 años de
conflicto armado a propósito de la fecha
de eeuu informó que se prepara para
retirar las farc de su lista de grupos
terroristas y tras un lustro del acuerdo
final muchas son las preguntas sobre la
implementación en el país precisamente
el secretario general de la onu antonio
guterres está en colombia para constatar
cuáles han sido los logros tras este
aporte
y debemos redoblar esfuerzos para
garantizar la sostenibilidad de los
proyectos con apoyo técnico y financiero
tierra y vivienda
saludo la entrega de terrenos por parte
del gobierno y confío que se extienda a
todas las áreas de reincorporación
la tierra es vital para lograr un
proceso sostenible que confiere
tranquilidad a los reincorporados y en
eeuu a millones de personas se desplazan
por aire y tierra para celebrar el día
de acción de gracias unos traslados que
se acercarían a los niveles antes de la
pandemia y que han llevado a las
aerolíneas a aumentar el personal y
también ofrezcan incentivos a sus
trabajadores al mismo tiempo los
expertos piden que se mantengan las
medidas de bioseguridad cuando el país
se enfrenta a un aumento de los casos
por kobe 19 veamos el informe que ha
preparado manuel a cano
las largas filas vuelven a los
aeropuertos en eeuu millones de personas
han decidio viajar para la celebración
del día de acción de gracias a pesar de
los crecientes números de contagios por
kobe 19 muchos estadounidenses se
desplazan para reunirse en familia
voy a viajar para el día de acción de
gracias' voy a ver a mi hija ancianos y
hasta ahora todo bien fue un poco
complicado encontrar estacionamiento
pero hasta ahora no parece estar
demasiado ocupado ya las esperas y las
multitudes recuerdan a la manera en que
transcurría la semana del festivo de
acción de gracias' antes de la pandemia
el viernes pasado las autoridades
estadounidenses reportaron el día más
concurrido en los aeropuertos desde que
se decretó la emergencia sanitaria con
224 millones de viajeros un récord que
también se vio en los ángeles
nuestro día más ocupado en lo que va del
año fue el viernes cuando 90.000
viajeros pasaron por el control de la
psa son cifras realmente alentadoras nos
dicen que la gente está lista y
dispuesta para regresar al aeropuerto y
viajar
al mismo tiempo se espera que 48 3
millones de personas viajen en su
vehículo hacia sus reuniones familiares
más de un millón que en el año pasado
aún con los precios de la gasolina más
altos desde 2014 los precios están altos
pero no están disuadiendo a los viajeros
una vez que deciden ir lo hacen solo
buscan otra forma de ajustar el
presupuesto unas previsiones que han
llevado a los expertos a pedir el
respeto de las medidas de bioseguridad
durante las celebraciones
y hoy se cumplen 30 años de la muerte de
freddie mercury una partida que
conmociona al mundo a pesar de que para
ese entonces el 24 de noviembre de 1991
llevaba mucho tiempo fuera de la vida
pública y corría todo tipo de
especulaciones sobre su salud
freddy murió en su hogar de kensington
en reino unido y con esto se fue uno de
los más formidables showman que tuvo la
historia de rock y también la música
para cursar era un gran pianista un
vocalista excepcional a pesar de su
adicción al tabaco diseño logos también
vestuarios y conocía los valores
musicales de su banda además de estar
dispuesto a lo que fuera para conquistar
al mundo con la legendaria queen con
música despedimos este informativo
[Aplausos]
[Música]
y bueno
directo